Hi, welcome back.
As we embark further into the value
investing space, I want to talk a little
bit about value contrarians. Value
investing in its contrarian form. In
essence, you're going against the grain
grain and hoping to make money off it.
So, let's set the stage. In contrarian
value investing, you begin again with
the proposition that investors
overreact. Investors overreact to good
news, investors overreact to bad news.
That makes it very similar to contrarian
trading that we talked about in the
context of trading. But here's where
value investors bring something more to
the table. In good contrarian value
investing, in addition to looking at
what the stock price has done and
assuming that investors overreact, you
look at the fundamentals to make sure
that you're on solid ground. Assuming
that overreaction is right, there is
evidence of course that investors
overreact. know that if you look at for
instance the serial correlations we
talked about over very long time periods
over fiveyear period stocks are more
likely to reverse themselves and
continue on the path they were in. If
you focus on individual stocks and
markets you get pretty much the same
effect. So let's start this discussion
of contrarian value investing by taking
what I call the bludgeon approach. The
bludgeon approach is in fact contrarian
trading. It's not contrarian value
investing, but in contrarian trading,
what do you do? You look at stocks that
have gone down the most over the last 6
months, the last year, the last 5 years.
You buy those stocks and you hold
expecting them to reverse themselves. I
talked about the Deborah Taylor research
in an earlier session. Debard and Taylor
created portfolios of 35 stocks which
had gone up the most and 35 stocks that
had gone down the most over the previous
year and then track what you'd have made
as returns over the next 5 years and the
results are pretty astonishing over the
next 5 years over the next 60 months. If
you bought the loser stocks you'd have
made substantially more returns almost
30%.
Then if you bought the winner stocks
which are actually down 10% relative to
the market. Look at the difference.
Close to 40% difference between the
loser stocks which emerged as the
winners and the winner stocks that
became the losers.
This was the base th this creates a
pretty solid basis for a contrarian
investing strategy, right? But not so
fast. If you take a closer look at those
winner and loser portfolios,
here are the things you need to worry
about. First is the loser portfolios
contain a significant number of really
lowric stocks $1.50$ dollar80 cent
shares and as we talked about earlier in
the context of trading costs those low
price stocks have much higher trading
costs the loser this study also found
that if you know or or a follow-up study
also found that creating the loser
portfolios in December creates much
better returns than creating the loser
portfolios in June. You're saying why?
There's some them some interreationship
between this loser effect and what we
noted is the January effect where
January is the best month of the year.
Many of these loser stocks deliver their
highest returns in January. And third,
you need a time horizon that allows you
to capture those excess returns. The
Debon Taylor study looked at the 60
months following, but a subsequent study
looked at what your returns would be for
winner and loser stocks by month of the
year. the cumulative returns. And if you
look at the first few months, the first
12 months after you create these
portfolios, winner stocks continue to
win and loser stocks continue to lose.
In fact, there's continuation. It's only
after the first year that you see the
reversal kick in. So if you go into the
strategy thinking you're going to make
money, you buy the loser of stocks and
you sell, you get impatient, you sell
after 9, 10 or 11 months, you're likely
to lose money with the strategy, not
make money. So it's a bludgeon strategy
because you're basing it on pricing. I'm
not sure where the word value even
belongs in the description of what you
do. You're a contrarian trader. Let's
dig a little deeper, though. Let's
suppose you truly want to create a
contrarian strategy that's built around
value. In this case, you want to invest
in stocks that have had a price drop,
but don't have a drop in fundamentals
that justify that price drop. In other
words, you're waiting for the stock
price to drop. And that stock price
drop, you then measure against what its
fundamentals did and said, "This stock
price drop looks like it's too much."
You're most likely to see this version
of contrary investing kick in when
stocks overreact to a news announcement
or a market crisis causes a selloff
across the board. Good stocks and bad
stocks or an entire sector gets marked
down. So in this more refined version of
contrary investing, you're looking at
the price and what it does, but it's a
starting point. You also look at
fundamentals.
So understand how this would work.
You're effectively looking for good
companies that get marked down, right?
But what's a good company? I'm going to
give you a framework that I found useful
in separating good from average to bad
companies. I look at three dimensions.
Revenue growth, margins, and
reinvestment. The very best companies,
great companies have high revenue
growth. They're able to grow fast, but
they're able to do so with high margins
and relatively little reinvestment.
Those are your great firms. At the other
end of the spectrum, your terrible firms
have low revenue growth, terrible
margins, and reinvest a lot to get
there. And the generic firm in the
middle has revenue growth, margins, and
reinvestment that are pretty much in the
middle. Great companies are able to grow
a lot, are profitable without having to
throw in huge amounts of reinvestment to
deliver that growth. So, you're saying
this is great. I can go out and find all
the great companies in the market. It's
not that difficult to do, but converting
into great returns is much messier. And
here's why.
If you invest in the very best
companies,
but you pay prices that reflect the fact
that they're very best companies, you're
not going to earn returns that reflect
the fact that these companies are among
the very best. In fact, this is from a
very early study that built off the the
well- readad and widely um bought book
by Tom Peters on excellent versus
unexellent companies where he identified
the characteristics that make for
excellent companies. I'm not going to
contest that book, but this study
actually took that book and said what
would happen to an investor who read
that book and went out and put his money
into excellent companies. Conversely,
what had happened to an investor who
read the same book and took a perverse
strategy of buying unexellent companies,
companies with the exact opposite
characteristics?
Well, in the 60 months following, the
people the $100 invest in unexellent
companies would have earned you a lot
more money than the $100 invested in
excellent companies. Sounds perverse,
but it depends on the price you get. In
fact, a follow-up study looked at
companies that were ranked based on
brand value from best to worst and found
that the companies which were ranked the
worst had much higher returns, 11.95%.
Companies that were ranked the best.
Often when you just invest in good
companies, very well-run companies,
excellent companies, you're not going to
earn the returns that reflect that
goodness if the price already reflects
it. Investing is a game of mismatches.
What I mean by that is you want to buy a
good company which the market thinks is
not a good company. Conversely, buying a
bad company that the market thinks is an
awful company might be a great strategy.
It's about finding mismatches.
So the essence of mismatches, the value
of the company reflects how good its
business is. The price of the company
reflects what the market thinks about
the business. So if you think the
company is good and the market also
thinks it's good, it's a match. You're
not going to make much money there. If
you think the company's good and the
market thinks it's bad, this is a great
investment. You go out and buy it. If
you think a company's bad and the market
perceives it good, this is your
overvalued stock. You sell it. And the
market thinks it's bad and you also
think it's bad, you're indifferent. So
there are two perspectives at play. Your
perspective on a company, is it a good
company? And the market's perspective,
is it a good company? The market's
perspective shows up in the price. Your
perspective shows up in your value.
You're looking for a mismatch. Now, if
you're a screener, there are ways in
which you can find this mismatch. But to
implement the strategy, here's how you
you go about it. First, you wait for a
trigger. The trigger can be a market
announcement that causes the stock price
to drop. I'll give you a personal
example. In 2021,
Facebook/Meta
saw its stock price collapse because of
a huge fiasco around an investment they
made in Metaverse. The earnings report
comes out, the Metaverse fiasco is
playing out. The stock price collapses,
drops by almost 60% from its high for
the year.
It's an entry point, right? But before I
make that entry point and I went and
looked at Facebook's fundamentals. It's
fundamental business is an online
advertising business which is really not
affected by the metaverse fiasco. I
looked at the fundamentals and I said
this is still a good company with a
great business at its core. The value of
the business has not dropped 60%.
There's a mismatch here between what the
market thinks about the company and what
I think about the company. And I did buy
Facebook. It had a happy ending. Not all
my stories have happy endings, but
that's how mismatches play out. Market
price collapses, but the fundamentals
don't support that collapse. If you stay
within the screening universe, though,
here's how you find mismatches.
You find a company that's cheap, has a
low pricing multiple, price earnings,
price to book, EV to EIT, EV to invested
capital, but don't have the fundamentals
to just you want a company that is
priced as a bad company, but has the
characteristics of a good company. So,
you have low PE ratio company market
thinks it's it's it's a bad company. But
if this company has high growth and low
risk and high payout, you find a good
company that is cheap. With price to
book, you have a low price to book
ratio, but you have high growth and low
risk and high return equity. You found a
mismatch. Conversely, you're looking for
expensive companies to sell short on. A
company that trades at a high price to
book, market has holds it in high
regard, but has low growth, high risk,
and low return equity. There's a
mismatch. game. The essence of pricing
is looking for mismatches. The pricing
multiple tells you what the market
thinks about the company. The
fundamentals tell you what you should
think about the company. And you're
looking for a mismatch between what you
think about the company and what the
market thinks.
So, if you are going to be a contrarian
investor, here are some of the qual
qualities you need to bring to the
table. The first is you're often
investing in companies where everybody
else is down in the company. So, you
need to have the self-confidence to go
against the grain.
Second, if you're investing other
people's money, you need to have clients
or investors who believe in you because
you're going to be picking companies
where the response is, "What are you
doing? Why would you do that?" And you
you should be able to convince them to
trust you in making this bet. Third, in
the immediate aftermath of buying these
companies, things might get worse rather
than better.
So, you need the patience to wait
through that and the stomach for that
short-term volatility because you're
going to get more bad news about this
company before things turn around. Even
if you're right about the fundamentals
and always and by now this should become
a common theme. Watch out for
transactions costs. Watch out for timing
issues because those can all get in the
way of execution.
Ultimately, summarize contrarian
investing. You're starting with the
building blocks of contrarian trading.
You're looking for stocks that have
dropped a lot built on the assumption
that investors overreact. But in the
case the value part of it is you look at
the fundamentals as well to make sure
that this price drop is not in fact
justified. There are some many companies
where the prices drop but they deserve
to drop. You're trying to separate the
companies that are cheap from the
companies that deserve to be cheap. And
in this case, the contrarian strategy
will often mean you're going against the
grain, and you got to have the stomach
and the patience to be able to wait it
out. I hope you found the session
useful, and I thank you very much for
listening.